gráfica el par ordenado 68 en el plano
ordenado que se muestra ese es el plano
coordenada el eje horizontal es el eje
de las x
el eje vertical es el eje de las íes
la convención para cuando nos dan un
paro ordenado como este que se muestra
acá es que la primera coordenada es la
coordenada x y la segunda coordenada
pues va a ser la y nos dicen que tenemos
una coordenada x de 6 significa que
vamos a contar 6 sobre el eje x
veamos uno vamos a escribirlo 1 2
aquí tenemos 3 aquí tenemos 4 y 5 y aquí
6 el que buscamos comenzamos desde el
punto cero el origen 0,0
nos movimos 6 lugares hacia la derecha
es esta parte de aquí ahora la
coordenada es menos 8 significa que
tenemos que desplazarnos hacia abajo 8
lugares en el eje y nos vamos al origen
y voy a marcar cada dos lugares este es
menos 2 este menos 3 aquí escribo menos
4 menos 5 y aquí menos 6 menos siete y
escribo menos 8 que es el que estoy
buscando entonces nos fuimos 6 lugares a
la derecha y ahora vamos a bajar 8
lugares hacia abajo verticalmente 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8
aquí está esta es la coordenada que nos
piden esto es la coordenada 6 menos 8 el
punto que nos pedían graficar y también
lo podemos hacer de esta manera aquí
arriba nos movemos 6 lugares y aquí
bueno dibujamos la línea sobre la que va
a estar nuestro punto equis y nos vamos
en el eje y vemos este menos 8 y ahí
dibujamos otra línea horizontal y donde
se aúnan estas dos líneas es el punto
que estamos buscando
como me gusta hacerlo es primero moverme
en el eje x y de ahí entonces bajar o
subir en el eje